[Music]
Welcome to Bible Answers Live, where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions.
Let's face it, it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible. With 66 books and more than
700,000 words, the Bible can generate a
lot of questions. If you'd like answers
to your Bible questions, you've come to
the right place. Now, here's your host,
Pastor Doug Bachelor, president and
speaker of Amazing Facts.
Welcome, listening friends. Would you
like to hear an amazing fact? We've all
heard the expression before that dog is
man's best friend. But in the ocean, a
man's best friend is probably the
dolphin. Maritime history is filled with
stories of dolphins helping drowning
sailors, rescuing people from sharks, or
guiding vessels through treacherous
waters. In 2004, a group of swimmers
were suddenly stalked by a 10-foot great
white shark off the northern coast of
New Zealand. Suddenly, a pod of dolphins
herded them together, circling the
swimmers for 40 minutes until the large
predator was driven away. In another
case, in the Red Sea, 12 divers were
lost for over 13 hours, and they were
surrounded by dolphins for the entire
time that were repelling the many sharks
that live in the area there. When a
rescue boat finally came near the area,
the dolphin pods showed them where the
stranded divers were by leaping into the
air and jumping towards the swimmers,
leading the boat onward. Likewise, in
the year 2000, it was a group of
dolphins that led fishermen to discover
six-year-old Ellen Gonzalez floating in
an inner tube out in the Atlantic Ocean
after his boat carrying Cuban refugees
sank. You know, the Bible says that God
has often used animals to rescue his
people. Stay with us, friends. We're
going to learn more as Amazing Facts
brings you this edition of Bible Answers
Live.
[Music]
You're listening to Bible Answers Live.
Honest answers to your Bible questions.
Our phone lines are now open. If you
have a Bible related question, call us
at 1 800 God Says. That's 1-800-4637297.
Now, let's join our host, Pastor Doug
Bachelor.
Welcome, listening friends to Bible
Answers Live. And uh this is a live
international interactive Bible study.
We'd invite you to call in with your
Bible questions. We have several lines
open right now. That number if you want
to call the studio, 800 God says. That's
8004637297.
One more time, if you want to call with
a Bible question, it's 8004637297.
And I am Doug Bachelor, our regular
co-host, Pastor Jean Ross, is he's
probably in the air somewhere, flying
back from New Zealand right now. But
we're glad that we have our associate
pastor, Marshall McKenzie, sitting in
the co-pilot seat. Evening, Marshall.
Good evening, Pastor Dove.
We're going to start with a word of
prayer and then we'll get to our
questions. Father in heaven, we just
want to commit this time to you. Pray
that through the spirit and even your
angels, you take charge of the calls
that come in and that you'll guide
through your word the answers that are
given. And so, please bless the Lord for
your kingdom and your glory in Jesus
name. Amen.
You know, Pastor Doug, I was just amazed
as you read and shared that story with
us, that amazing fact about dolphins and
God's providence in leading those
dolphins.
That's right. And you know, there's
several more stories that I could share.
I I've lived around the water for uh
several years of my life and u I've
heard just some amazing stories about
dolphins, boys that were drowning, even
a dog that was drowning. A dolphin was
once found nudging it back to the
surface and helping it ashore. And they
seem to be one of the many animals that
God has wired with some sort of
compassion or altruism and empathy. And
um you know in the Bible you can find a
couple of cases where God used animals
to save people. One story that pops into
my mind is in first kings chapter 17
when Elijah had to flee out into the
wilderness during a time of famine. And
it says that the word of the Lord told
him to go stay by the brook cherish
which flows into the Jordan. And ravens
brought him bread and food in the
morning and bread and food in the
evening. and he drank from the brook.
God used these ravens and it is true
that you know ravens are are very smart
animals. They can live I think up to 25
years.
Incredible.
Yeah. And u of course there's a story in
the Bible where God even spared the life
of Balum because the donkey did not walk
into a path of destruction. So he was
saved by a donkey. But it's incredible
when you study the the intelligence that
God even has in his creatures. here in
California. I saw a documentary about
there's a gorilla that's over 40 years
old now named Coco that's been basically
taught to talk with sign language and I
forget it knows like over a thousand
words but it it talks in sentences and
sign languages and the gorilla
incredible.
So just imagine how different it will be
in heaven in the earth made new
communicating.
You know my my children talk about that
all the time what it's going to be like
with the animals what we're going to be
able to do with the animals. Uh, they
love the animals.
Yeah, I think there there'll be a whole
level of communication that maybe Adam
and Eve had in the garden that we've
lost somewhat now.
But, you know, maybe you'd like to know
more about this God that made the world
and the wonders that he has in creation,
amazing facts. Would like to offer you a
free gift tonight. It's a book called
Amazing Wonders of Creation. It's even
got a dolphin on the cover. A beautiful
book that will inspire you and it is
free. We only ask that when you read it,
share it with someone. Here's the number
for the free resource. That's 8008356747
for that book that talks about the
wonders of creation. 8008356747.
Now, if you have a Bible question, I see
two lines still open. Good chance you'll
get your question on tonight's program.
That number is 8004637297.
8004637297.
If no one picks up right away, it's just
because our callers are uh answering
other calls. And be patient. They'll get
to your call. All right. Are we ready to
head towards the phones?
We're ready. Our first call actually is
from Aaron and Carmichael. Um Aaron,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live and Pastor Doug Bachelor.
Hi. Um I'm calling in regards to Romans
7 or excuse me 8:17.
Okay.
Sorry. Which refers to us being joint
hes with Christ. And what does that
actually mean?
Well, in in the same way that Jesus um
inherited eternal life, the Bible tells
us, you know, when he rose from the
dead, we're going to rise if we die
before he comes. Of course, those that
are alive and remain when the Lord comes
will just be transformed. Christ had a
glorified body. We will have glorified
bodies. And Jesus told the apostles that
u we're going to live and reign with him
in the kingdom. You also find that in
Revelation 20.
And so we inherit the word joint heirs.
An heir is someone who inherits
something. We inherit because of
Christ's sacrifice
eternal life and a place in his kingdom.
You know, it it just reminds me of the
verse in Revelation where we will sit
with him on his throne.
That's in Revelation chapter 3.
That's another good point. That's right.
So, does that kind of answer what you're
wondering, Aaron? Well, yeah, because
I've had some people uh tell me that
that literally means we're going to be
like like him in almost every aspect.
And they use this as a verse to justify
that. And I said, I don't think that
quite they were trying to make it almost
seem like it meant more
like we're going to be God or something
or gods.
Well, some Yeah. Like a god under a god
or something like that. Yeah. No, but
we'll we'll just be really his
ambassadors in the kingdom and we'll be
able to go through limitless space and
just, you know, bear witness to God's
goodness and his salvation. But, uh, no,
there's only one God. And, uh, but we're
going to be able to reign with him in in
that um, uh, we're going to have a
special place. God is moving the capital
of his universe to this world when the
new Jerusalem comes down. That's in
Revelation 21. So, what a privilege.
Uhhuh.
Did that help? Hey, we do have a lesson
we'll be happy to share with you for
free and it talks about God's city in
space. It talks about the redeemed and
the new earth.
And u you know what I think you'd really
enjoy? Actually, we have a book called
Heaven Is It Real? And and it's in that
book, Heaven Is It Real. Here's the
number for the free offer. 8008356747.
Also, Aaron, you can even go to the
Amazing Facts website, and I think that
is one of our books you can download for
free. It's called Heaven Is It Real.
Just go to amazingfacts.org.
It's easy to remember. Amazing facts.
Now, it's not FAX. Some people have said
I I couldn't get the website. It's
ficts.
Amazing facts.org.
God bless. Appreciate your call. And
let's see who's next in line.
Yes. Our next caller, Pastor Doug, is
Pat from Las Vegas, Nevada. Um Pat,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live and Pastor Doug Bachelor.
Hi, Pastor Doug. How are you this
evening?
Doing good. Thank you for calling.
Oh, you bet. Uh, what I'm calling about,
Pastor Doug, is John 20 verse 23. Uh, if
you forgive the sins of any, they are
forgiven them. If you retain the sins of
any, they are retained. And I know that
Cathosis and the priest uh have a
confession and they do they do that. And
I just got the impression from the
reading that Christ was uh passing that
on for not necessarily just Catholic
priests, but passing that on for
Christians to some way or another get
blessed in order to do that. It doesn't
seem to me that he's saying just for
those the apostles right there. Now,
that's why that's my question, I guess.
What is it? How do where does it start
and stop? Is it just solely for them and
then once that they the ones he uh
issued that proclamation to they died
that it's ended?
You know, there's a couple of ways I've
heard this explained. First thing, let's
let's address what it does not mean. Um
God does not give people the right to
choose who is forgiven and saved. Uh
that would be pretty frightening if
mortals were deciding who is going to be
forgiven and who is not and who's going
to be saved. Uh the way I've heard it
explained,
is it Jesus saying that? Well, let me
let me tell you what I do think it
means, and I think that'll help a
little.
Um, when whenever we share the gospel,
in sharing the gospel, we're sharing the
forgiveness of God.
When we do this, they're forgiven. Now,
you notice when this verse appears, it
appears right after it says he breathed
on them and said, "Receive the Holy
Spirit."
And if you read in Acts chapter uh Acts
1:8, it says, "I'm going to give you the
spirit to be my witnesses." And then the
Holy Spirit's poured out and they start
preaching. The purpose for the Holy
Spirit is to share the gospel. Christ
said in sharing the gospel, you will be
sharing uh eternal forgiveness. So
that's one way it's understood. The
other way I've heard it understood is
the apostles were also given through the
spirit authority
uh in the church about who would be
received into the church. And sometimes
people were disciplined and put out of
the church. That doesn't mean they're
deciding whose sins are forgiven, but
they're deciding they did have the right
to decide who was going to be in the
church and out of the church because of
their behavior. Sometimes after a person
accepted the Lord, like this guy Simon,
he started to try to sell salvation. And
in first Corinthians, Paul talks about a
man living with his stepmother and she
should that person should be put out of
the church, the son rather. And and so,
okay,
I've heard it understood that way also.
But I don't think he's saying you get to
decide who is forgiven, who's not
because no mortal should really have
that right. And in the Bible's pretty
clear, God and God only can forgive sin.
That's in Mark chapter 2.
So, I appreciate your call. And let me
just think if there's a book that
specifically deals with that subject
that we could offer uh about
forgiveness. Uh you know, I've got a
sermon. And if you go to the Amazing
Facts website, uh, I've got a sermon
there that you can download and it's
called 70* 7. If you just type in Doug
Bachelor 70* 7, it might even pop up on
YouTube. We've been surprised how many
people are kind enough to repost our
sermons on YouTube. Hey, thank you for
your call, Pat. I appreciate it.
Pastor Doug, our next call is from John
in New Jersey. Uh, John, you're on the
air with Bible Answers Live and Pastor
Doug Bachelor, your question.
Hello. Hello. Thank you very much. Um, I
was listening to your program last
Sunday night and a young a woman called
in that she was suffering from anxiety
and depression and uh I have a question
but uh but I just I I was so moved by
her call and I tried to get I couldn't
get through last week. I hope she's
listening. Um there there's a lot of
scriptures
about afflictions and consolation when
we have afflictions. And I found a whole
like four pages of script scripture from
Genesis through Revelation about that uh
in a in a topical Bible that's been
around. It's a big reference topical
Bible there where the topics are listed
alphabetically.
Your screener said don't mention any
names. So I am I am I not allowed to
mention the name of the book or the like
I think that'd be fine. Go ahead. You
got to want to reference that for
somebody.
It's called it's called Naves like like
Navy but with an E at the end. NAV Nav's
topical Bible and it was written in
1898. And if she looks in that book
under afflictions and within afflictions
under consolation in there many
scriptures in there that have helped me.
It's been like a bomb healing bomb for
my soul. And the word of God is living
and working powerfully. So it really can
heal and change you.
No, that's a good reference. As a matter
of fact, the Naves topical Bible uh
comments are in many Bibles and you can
even mention u I'll mention it I guess
is that people can go online and Naves
is public domain meaning that you'll
find it for free on online. Anybody can
read it. I use it when I I do a topical
concordance sometimes.
Hey, I appreciate you sharing that. And
there are a lot of people out there that
struggle with uh you know variety of
challenges and they love to find these
Bible promises that would give them
encouragement. And so I appreciate you
sharing that John. Uh by the way we do
have a book that talks about the secret
weapon in understanding the power of the
Bible. It's called the ultimate
resource. And we'll send you a free copy
of that John just for being so helpful.
It's called the ultimate resource. Just
call our resource number 8008356747.
By the way, if some of you just want
prayer, you know, we're talking about
people that might be struggling with
challenges, we do have chaplain standing
by at that number, 800 8356747.
They'll be happy to pray with you. Thank
you, John.
Our next question is from Jim in
Bedford, Pennsylvania. Jim, you're on
the air with Bible Answers Live, Pastor
Doug Bachelor.
Uh thank you pastor Doug. Uh so we've
been having this discussion in our
church regarding the Holy Spirit and
some are saying that we have the Holy
Spirit from the from birth that the Holy
Spirit is with us and in us. Others then
say uh regarding regarding incident
events like the pent Pentecost that the
holy we don't receive the Holy Spirit
until we receive Jesus into our life. I
was wondering if you could speak to that
and maybe clear that up a little bit.
That's a very good and a very important
question. I'm glad you asked it. Um it's
a misunderstanding for someone to say
just because you're born you
automatically have the Holy Spirit.
There are a couple of rare individuals
like John the Baptist where it says he
was filled with the spirit from his
mother's birth. The reason it's
mentioned is because that is not the
norm. Typically, when a person receives
Christ, a verse for that is Acts chapter
2. Peter says, "Repent,
be baptized, and you will receive the
gift of the Holy Spirit." He didn't say,
"You have it." He said, "You'll receive
it."
Jesus, even at his baptism, the Holy
Spirit came down. And that's in Matthew
chapter 3. And um so now the Holy Spirit
can also come in different degrees. A
person receiving the gift of the spirit.
It can come gently like a wind. Jesus
says in John chapter 3. Uh sometimes it
you get baptized or totally filled with
the Holy Spirit as David did when he was
anointed king. And as at Pentecost when
the Holy Spirit came and they were you
know suddenly preaching in other
languages. So being baptized in the
spirit is different from just the power
of God's spirit that may be moving in a
person's life that helps us resist
temptation helps us listen to the voice
of God and be his witnesses. And that's
Acts chapter 1 verse 8. It says I will
give you my spirit and you will be my
witnesses. So uh the spirit does come
when we come to Jesus. Now the spirit
works in our life even before we accept
Christ. But it's the spirit bringing
conviction. Jesus said the Holy Spirit
will even convict you of sin. It's the
Holy Spirit that leads us to repent of
our sins so that we can be filled with
the Holy Spirit when we surrender to the
Lord. It's kind of like a marriage. You
know, you don't just marry someone the
day you meet them. There's a courtship.
And baptism is like the marriage and
then you get the special gifts of the
spirit. But the Holy Spirit's working in
your life and dating you before that.
It's kind of convicting and comforting
and helping you know God is real before
you even make the final surrender. And
when you turn to the Lord, you're giving
him permission to fill you with his
spirit. Uh great question. And so I'm
sorry, Jim, did that answer what you're
asking?
Well, so what the we we what you're
you're agreeing with is that the Holy
Spirit is in the world
uh all the all the time in in around in
the world and around us.
Well, yeah. When God created the world,
it says the spirit moved on the face of
the water. So, you've you've got the the
the spirit is certainly in the world,
but the spirit is working in the lost to
convict them of their sin. You know,
back in the days of Noah, if you look in
just Genesis 6:3,
uh God said, "My spirit will not always
strive with man." In other words,
there's going to be a limit to my spirit
trying to lead you to turn from your
sin. And when Noah got done preaching
and building the ark, the Holy Spirit
was withdrawn and that whole world
perished except for Noah and his family.
So, God works with us if we reject the
spirit. Uh even chapter 2 says, "Don't
grieve the Holy Spirit." Uh, you know,
the Holy Spirit's working to bring us to
God, but if we keep resisting, that's
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit, which
is the unpardonable sin. Hey, we do have
a free book we can give you, Jim, and
it's called Life in the Spirit. You'll
really enjoy that. Life in the Spirit.
Just call 8008356747.
We'll send you a free copy of Life in
the Spirit. Or you can read it online
for free at amazingfacts.org.
And that does free up another phone
line. And if you have a Bible question,
here's that number. 8004637297.
We'll bring your questions into
headquarters here. 8004637297.
And um Okay, Pastor Marshall, who's
next? We've got Lewis from Detroit,
Michigan. Uh Lewis, you're on the air
with Bible Answers Live. Pastor Doug
Bachelor.
Hello.
Hi. You're on, Lewis. And your question
tonight,
I want to know what is the difference
from being possessed by demons and
taking the mark of the beast.
Well, everybody that takes the mark of
the beast probably is possessed because
when you have the seal of God, you have
the spirit of God. And when you have the
mark of the beast, you've got the spirit
of the enemy. And it the most fearful
curses in the Bible are proclaimed on
those who receive the mark of the beast.
It says, "The wrath of God's indignation
will be poured on them without measure."
And it tells us the seven last plagues
in Revelation fall upon those who
worship the beast. And so, if someone
worships the beast, they probably got
the spirit of the devil. Now, whether
they're going to act like they are
possessed with a legion of demons, I
don't know, but they're definitely lost.
There are people out there that are very
wicked that know how to act in a
civilized way, so they can fool people.
Uh the devil's a shrewd operator. But uh
yeah, those who have the mark of the
beast are lost. But let's talk about the
seal of God. And if a person wants to be
saved, they want the seal of God. We
have a lesson. We can send you a free
copy on of a lesson that talks about the
seal of God. And u it's actually in the
lesson called what is the mark of the
beast?
Is that right?
That's right.
And so uh Pastor Marshall's in charge of
the amazing facts publishing department.
So, I'm I know he'll give me the answers
on all our publications. If you want a
free copy of the book on the mark of the
beast and the seal of God, just call
Amazing Facts, call that resource line.
It's open now. 800 835-6747
if you want to understand that subject.
8008356747.
We'll send it to you for free. Thank you
for your call, Lewis. And that opens
another line. Again, the number to the
studio is 8004637297.
Uh, next question from Alex in New
Mexico. Alex, you're on the air with
Bible Answers Live and Pastor Doug
Bachelor.
Alex, Pastor Doug.
Oh, there you go.
Uh, my name's Alex. Uh, nice to to
listen to you tonight and uh I wanted to
say God bless you for bringing this uh
program to life.
Thank you. And uh I wanted to ask a
question. Is it possible for man today
to uh I think there was a scripture in
the Bible where it said um
the uh many wise men and and prophets
wish they knew what you knew what you
know and never knew it.
Yes.
And and there was another one in
Proverbs 23
1:23.
In Proverbs 123. Um do you have it
there?
Well, I can look up Proverbs 123 real
quick.
Yes.
And uh and did you did you already get
that, Marshall? I do. It says, "Turn at
my Is this just want to make sure, Alex,
this is the one? Turn at my rebuke.
Surely I will pour out my spirit on you
and I will make my words known to you.
Yes. Uh his words known to us and uh
these things have come to me in
different ways. Uh like uh the word
listen there was L for listen and then
there's I s and then pen you know listen
there is 10 ten commandments I think I
believe that's what it's trying to tell
me. um things like this. This is just a
one thing that's
what what's the question?
The question has uh uh the spirit can um
give you messages in the night that you
want to tell people in the daytime.
Yeah. you know, the Holy Spirit and many
times in the Bible, God gave visions and
messages to prophets and some of his uh
even kings and um they'd be messages
that and that he would they would share
during the day. Sometimes it might be
through a dream, it might be through a
prophecy, a vision and um you know that
doesn't happen very often with average
people. God periodically will raise up a
prophet where you know he gives them
kind of special revelations and messages
and of course he did that with the
apostles too. Um sometimes he gives us
dreams and it's just for us personally.
He might have some personal guidance
that he gives us in a dream and the Lord
still does that with people today.
There's a verse in um what is it? Joel
chapter 2 he says in the last days I'll
pour out my spirit on all flesh.
Sons and daughters will prophesy. Your
old men will dream dreams. your young
men will see visions. And so, yeah, it
does happen. Let's see. Um, Pastor
Marshall, can we get one more call
before our break? Thank you, Alex.
Appreciate your question.
We can, Ronald from San Bernardino,
California. Ronald, you're on the air
with Bible Answers Live and Pastor Doug
Bachelor.
Okay. Thank you for taking my call.
Sure.
In uh Matthew 12:31,
it states that whoever speaks against
the Holy Spirit will not be forgiven.
Does that mean that you're going to go
to hell? You can't be forgiven at all.
Well, someone who grieavves away the
Holy Spirit is uh it's the spirit of God
that leads us to repentance. And u in
that verse, and I'll read it for
everybody, therefore I say to you, every
sin and blasphemy will be forgiven men,
but blasphemy against the spirit will
not be forgiven. So if a person is
unforgiven, they're lost if they're
unforgiven by God. So, and then he goes
on to say, "Anyone who speaks a word
against the Son of Man, it'll be
forgiven him. But whoever speaks against
the Holy Spirit, it will not be forgiven
him either in this age or the age to
come." Well, that's that's pretty
definitive. And so, everyone wants to
know what is blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit because it is the unforgivable
sin. I always like to remind people,
don't forget the good part. Christ says,
"All manner of sin and blasphemy will be
forgiven." God forgives all kinds of
sin. He's forgiven in the Bible murder
and adultery and even different kinds of
blasphemy. But blasphemy against the
Holy Spirit is perpetually resisting the
work and the voice of the Holy Spirit.
So that we resist repenting. We resist
the conviction. And this is what Judas
did. And he ended up hanging himself.
This is what Balam did and he was
killed. And this is what King Saul did.
He fell on his own sword. And so when we
grieve away the Holy Spirit, we're just
like with King Saul, he got into trouble
and it says God would not speak to him
either through dream or vision or priest
or prophet. And um I think it's I forget
the verse, but it's in Proverbs where it
says if we turn away our ear from
hearing the law,
even our prayer is an abomination. So
resisting hearing God can get to the
point where it's the unpardonable sin.
Now, I got a book on that I'll send you
for free, Ronald. Would you like that?
Uh, yeah, sure.
It's it's the the title scary. It's
called Beyond Mercy, but it's actually
an encouraging book if you just call the
number 800 8356747.
Tell them you're listening to Bible
Answers Live and that we've just offered
you the book Beyond Mercy. We'll send
you a free copy of that. It talks about
what does it mean? What is the sin
against the Holy Spirit? And it's also
an encouraging book. tells you about all
that God does and to forgive us. Hey
friends, we are going to simply catch
our breath and take a brief break and
have some station identifications, but
we got more Bible questions coming. Stay
tuned.
[Music]
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a moment.
Life's a curious thing. I mean, just
when things seem under control, wham!
You're hit with something new. Your
marriage is good. Suddenly, it's on the
brink of divorce.
The job's great, and then it's gone, and
so is your life savings.
You feel healthy. Then your doctor gives
the bad news. What's coming next? You
could look to the stars, but they don't
have the answers.
But this does. The Prophecy Study Bible
by Amazing Facts. This Bible's special.
It's 27 personal study guides lead you
on a life-changing journey through God's
word to discover real answers to life's
questions. From health and relationships
to family and the future, the hope's in
here.
Get your amazing facts. Prophecy Study
Bible today by calling 8005387275
or visit afbookstore.com.
Can't get enough Amazing Facts Bible
study? You don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truthfilled
programming? Visit the Amazing Facts
Media Library at aftv.org.
At aftv.org,
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge. 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week, right from your
computer or mobile device. Visit
aftv.org.
[Music]
Every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life.
So, what are you waiting for? Get the
answers you need for a fuller, richer,
more confident life. You're listening to
Bible Answers Live.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. If you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air,
please call us next Sunday between 7:00
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program.
Call 8008356747.
Once again, that's 8008356747.
Now, let's join Pastor Doug Bachelor for
more Bible Answers Live.
We are back on the air and this is Bible
Answers Live. And for those that may
have joined along the way, it is a live
international interactive Bible study.
And if you have a question, as we
mentioned, we've got some lines open
still. I see woo, three, four lines
open. So, give us a call. Here's the
number. 8004637297.
If you have a Bible question,
8004637297.
We got some friendly operators that'll
just jot down what your question is and
where you're calling from and we'll take
your call. Uh my name is Doug Bachelor
and I'm joined today by Pastor Marshall
McKenzie who is an associate at our
church in Granite Bay as well as the
publishing director at Amazing Facts.
Pastor Ross is in route returning from a
speaking engagement in New Zealand where
they talk just a little funny. But we're
going to go back to our phones. And
who's next? Um Sean from Danville,
Illinois. Uh Sean, you're on the air
with Bible Answer Live and Pastor Doug.
This is Hello.
Hi Sean. How are you doing?
I'm fine. It's a blessing and a
privilege to speak with you, Pastor
Bachelor.
Likewise. um miss Pastor Ross, but we
definitely uh thank uh thank the Lord
for your for his uh replacement this
evening.
Sure.
Um I uh my question is I was uh
confronted with about um what uh the
invest something about the investigative
judgment.
Yeah.
Someone who had been what what is there
any viable foundation for that? Yeah,
that's a big word, but it it's really a
simple principle is uh the judgment
really is broken up into three phases.
You've got some judgment takes place
before Jesus even comes. And I think
people know that intuitively because
when the Lord comes, he's giving
rewards. The dead in Christ rise. That
means they they've already it's been
determined they are in Christ. And um it
says the wicked flee from his presence.
So people are getting saved or lost when
Jesus comes. Um you read in um Peter,
where is that verse in
1st Peter 4:17?
Yeah. Why don't you read that to us? You
got it handy?
Yeah. It says uh for this time uh has
come for judgment to begin at the house
of God. And if it begins with us first,
what will be the end of those who do not
obey the gospel of God? Yeah. So there
is a judgment that starts before Christ
even comes. Um and Jesus even said the
Holy Spirit is coming to the world for
judgment. So, the first fra phase of
judgment called the investigative
judgment. Sometimes it's called the
pre-advent judgment. In other words, a
judgment that takes place before Christ
comes. When Jesus comes, he's separating
the wheat from the chaff. So,
something's happened already. Um, then
you got a judgment during the 10,000
years where the righteous are involved.
And that's where Paul says, "Do you not
know that you'll judge angels?" And
we're agreeing with God's judgments
basically because when we get to heaven,
we're going to see some people there and
we're going to think, "How'd they get
here?" We're going to see some people
missing. We're going to think, why
aren't they here? And God is going to
let us look at the books and see that
there's a reason why um can you imagine
the Apostle Paul, he gets to heaven and
Stephen is there. No, I say it
backwards. Steven gets to heaven. Paul
is there. And the last time that Steven
saw Paul or Saul, he was stoning
Christians. And Stephven's wondering,
what is he doing here? Well, the angels
will show him the books, say he was
converted in a dramatic way. So, there's
that judgment. And then the final
executive judgment is the white throne
judgment when God reigns fire down upon
the wicked. Everyone is punished
according to what they deserve. They're
cast in the lake of fire. And that's
really like the third phase or of the
judgment. So the investigative judgment
is a judgment there where Christ is our
high priest. He's in heaven right now.
And u
you read about it. Let me give you
another verse. You read about it in
Daniel chapter 7. Oh, is it verse um
where it says one like the son of man
came to the ancient of days
right around 1314.
Yeah, verses 13 and 14. Hey, we'll send
you a lesson on that. Would you like a
free lesson that talks about uh God sets
a date for the judgment?
Yes.
Yeah. We've got a whole lesson that
covers all the scriptures. It'll be
really good. We'll send you a free copy,
Sean. All you got to do is call this
number 8008356747.
Uh, I don't think you can read the
lesson for free online at can he?
He should be able to.
Oh, if but he has to go to like Bible
universe universe. Correct.
There's another website. You can read
that for free at bibleuniverse.com.
And otherwise we'll send you a copy. 800
8356747
tell the operators and
and God sets a date for the judgment is
the name of the lesson. Hey, thank you
very much Sean. Appreciate your patience
and want to remind our callers that be
listening. Sometimes while you're
waiting, you mute your call and uh we're
saying hello. Hello and you can't hear
us or we can't hear you. Anyway, who's
next?
Uh Philip from Glenn Falls, New York.
Philip, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live and Pastor Doug.
Uh God bless you guys. Thanks for taking
my call.
Hey, thanks Phillip and your question.
Um I would like some clarification on a
verse out of the book of Luke chapter 9
and it's verse 27. And it says, "But I
say to you truthfully, there are some of
those standing here who will not taste
death until they see the kingdom of
God." This is also cross referenced in
Matthew 16:18
and Mark 9. Yes.
Yes. What does that mean?
The answer to that passage in all three,
Matthew, Mark, and Luke, after Jesus
makes this cryptic statement, some of
you here will not taste death till you
see the kingdom of God come. It says
something happened six days later in
Luke. I think it says about 8 days
later, but in Matthew and Mark it says
six days later. Uh the difference is
Luke says about 8 days later because
he's interviewing people getting the
story. Um he takes them up on a
mountain. Moses and Elijah appear. Jesus
is glorified as he will be during the
second coming. God the father speaks.
You got the glory of the father. You got
the angels around Jesus. You got Moses.
Moses died but he's resurrected. He's
represents those who come with Jesus
that have been resurrected. uh and
Elijah never died. He is simply
translated to heaven. Some will be alive
and remain when Christ comes. What those
disciples experienced after Jesus makes
this statement, Peter, James, and John
is a miniature picture of the second
coming.
I see.
So Christ on the Mount of Trans mount of
transfiguration then
that's the fulfillment of his prophecy
when he's some of you standing here will
not taste of death till you see the
kingdom of God. In other words, I'm
going to give you a window, a little
picture into the second coming and then
it's fulfilled in the next verses.
And I was just thinking in second Peter,
Peter talks about this experience.
Actually gives his own testimony of it.
He said he'll never forget it when he
hears it. Oh, you know what? You just
reminded me. We have a book on that.
We'll send you a free book exactly on
that verse if you'd like, Philip. It's
called uh The Two Witnesses.
Yeah.
And if you call Amazing Facts, we'll
send you a copy. It's an easy read and
it's a if I say so myself I wrote it.
It's a great story. 800 8356747.
It's called The Two Witnesses. I think
you can read it for free online. Just so
people know, we're not out there just to
make money. We give a lot of this away.
And uh and if you want to read it online
for free, just go to Amazing Facts.
You'll see a button that says our free
library. Amazingfacts.org.
If you type in amazingfacts.com, you'll
still get there. Okay. Thank you,
Phillip. And your next caller is uh
Scott. Scott, you're from Milwaukee,
Wisconsin. You're on the air with Bible
Answers Live and Pastor Doug.
Good evening, gentlemen. How you doing
tonight?
Better than we deserve. Thank you for
your call.
Well, thank you very much. Uh I have a
question about gifts of the Holy Spirit.
Um, a church I just left uh said that
the gifts of the spirit left as soon as
the the apostles of Jesus Christ died.
Uh, I cannot find that anywhere in
scripture. So, my question is then, who
can receive the Holy Spirit's gifts?
Well, I I would respectfully disagree
with anybody that says that the gifts of
the spirit died with the apostles. Uh
the the reason they come up with that is
because sometimes you don't find uh some
of the same dramatic manifestation of
the gifts in modern times. And so they
say, "Well, we don't want to say God's
lost his power, so we'll just say those
gifts all stopped back in the days of
the apostles." But that's not true.
You've heard this before then.
Yeah. All the gifts of the spirit, I
believe, are still available. Let me
give you an example. You read in Joel
chapter 2, and it says, "It'll come to
pass in the last days I'll pour out my
spirit on all flesh. Your sons and your
daughters will prophesy." I just read
this a minute ago. So, the gift of
prophecies there. Uh the dreams and
visions. Jesus said you'll speak with
other tongues. I believe in the gift of
tongues. I don't believe the gift of
tongues the way it's being used by some
churches. You know, with every gift,
it's often abused. And there are false
prophets and there are true prophets.
There's false tongues and there's true
tongues. And um Jesus said in the last
days there'd be false prophets. Why did
he say don't believe in any prophets?
Because there will also be true
prophets. And so, um, the idea that the
gifts have stopped, Paul says, you know,
Paul, he's converted after all, he's the
last of the apostles. He says in 1
Corinthians, uh, chapter 12, he talks
about the spiritual gifts. And it would
seem, why would he go to all that
trouble to outline what the purpose of
the gifts is and then say, "No, this is
only going to last until we all die." He
doesn't say that.
I was just going to add to what you're
saying. Peter also in Acts when he
quotes Joel chapter 2 says, "This is
just a partial fulfillment." So, in the
last days, you're going to see this all
over again.
Yeah.
The the apostles received the Holy
Spirit in like a former reign power. In
the last days, before the second coming,
the church will receive the spirit of
God in a latter rain power. But God's
power is still there. I mean, I just
came back from New Guinea last week
where they still see all kinds of
miracles and signs and wonders and and u
I've even heard of, you know, children
being resurrected when missionaries
prayed and just some amazing stories. So
God's power is still there. And if we
had more faith, we'd see more examples.
But we're living in a very faithless,
secular time.
Indeed. Indeed, we are. Yeah.
Hey, I do have a book I can send you
that talks about one. I got one on the
Holy Spirit, and then I've got one
specifically on tongues, which is a gift
of the spirit that is much disputed and
uh it'll I I believe in the gift of
tongues, but I believe people are
confused about it sometimes. And um
go ahead. What were you saying? the the
this this place did say is that well
they didn't believe in tongues because
well that's the easiest one to fake.
Well, yes, but doesn't mean it's not
happening.
Well, people fake prophecy all the time.
I hear people get up and they even call
themselves prophets on TV and they make
all kinds of crazy predictions and some
have predicted the second coming on
numerous occasions. Obviously, they were
false prophets. Uh so um yeah you can
fake any gift of the spirit but that
doesn't mean you discount the real thing
because one of the gifts of the spirit
is preaching and we so we still love
preachers you know one of the gifts of
the spirit is uh is you know um
administration
and we still have administration so the
other gifts of the spirit are still
here. Hey thank you Scott. If you like
that book on uh the uh fruits of the
spirit we'll be happy to send you a
copy. I think it's called life in the
spirit rather life in the spirit and
just call 8008356747
and the gift on tongue the book on
tonesues you can read that uh just go to
amazingfacts.org
type up the if anyone does a search Doug
bachelor understanding tongues I think
you can read the book right there on the
internet appreciate your call
u next question is from Bill in New
Jersey Bill you're on the air with Bible
answers live and pastor Doug
Hi, thanks for taking my call.
Absolutely.
Um hopefully a quick an easy question.
Uh just recently I watched a documentary
where um something that I've been
referring to for over 30 years. Uh they
would they discounted 1 John 5:7. Uh
I've always used that for proof of the
Trinity. And I'm just curious uh what
they said was that was something that
was added in later after the the the the
books were written. Um do you have any
consation on that?
Well that it is true that when you look
at the the old manuscripts of the New
Testament and they got different names
for some of them. You got the saticus
and the vaticaninus and the text
receptus or the received text that some
of the oldest manuscripts don't have
that line in there. And so they argue
that it was added. They because they
say, well, if it's the oldest
manuscript, then it must have been added
in the newer ones. But that's not true.
Some of the newer manuscripts, and even
the newer manuscripts are thousand years
old. Some of the newer manuscripts were
copied from even older manuscripts,
meaning that they may be more accurate.
So, um, and there are a few verses in
the end of Mark that are missing. Well,
the reason they're missing is because
basically it was the end of the book and
just got worn off or cut off. And, and,
um, but I believe that verse is valid.
But you know what? Our theology, whether
that verse is there or not, the theology
about the Trinity is pretty clear in the
Bible. You can find, I wrote a book on
it, and there's just all kinds of
support in the Bible for the three
persons of the Godhead all the way back
in Genesis where God says, "Let us make
man in our image." And uh Jesus said,
"Baptize in the name of the father, son,
and holy spirit." And at the baptism of
Christ, you got the voice of the father.
You've got the holy spirit coming like a
dove. You got Jesus, the son, and the
water. And so, yeah, there, you know, I
believe there are three that bear
witness in heaven. I think that was in
the original when John wrote it, and it
maybe was missing from a later
manuscript.
It's more likely when they wrote these
things by hand, it's more likely that
scribes would skip a line, I've often
been typing things and copying things
and I missed the whole line, than that
they would manufacture a line.
So, I think that just the old manuscript
they're looking at, it was forgotten as
the scribes were copying these things.
They didn't have Xerox machines. They
didn't have email back then. It was all
manually done. And sometimes you had
human error.
Yeah. It just it just shook me really
badly at first because it's been like 35
years now. I've always been referring to
that that particular passage and going
back to the beginning of John to show
that Christ is the word and the word is
God, you know.
Oh, John. Yeah. Well, Jesus is the word.
It's It's in several places in the
Gospel of John and in the Bible,
right?
So, uh, yeah, don't fret. You've got a
good foundation. You know what? I If
you're ever in doubt, believe too much
of the Bible before you start believing
too little of it. If you're going to
make a mistake, make the mistake of
believing it's all the inspired word of
God. Don't start questioning this verse
and that verse because then your your
foundation like one grain of sand at a
time, it begins to crumble in the storm.
And I find when people start saying,
"Well, this verse doesn't mean that and
that verse isn't there." Pretty soon
they got a pretty shaky foundation.
And you know, but to be honest with you,
that's the conclusion I came to myself.
I've always believed that it was the
inspired word of God. So if that's the
case, then obviously man must defend me
that documentary must been wrong. Thank
you.
Yep.
Hey, absolutely. And uh we do have a
book that I think you'll enjoy called
The Ultimate Resource and it talks about
the uh the word of God and its
dependability. We'll send you a free
copy of The Ultimate Resource. Just ask
for it. 800 8356747.
And uh I think we still got a couple
lines open. 8004637297
will bring you into the studio.
8004637297
with your Bible questions. Yeah. Let's
see who's next on line. We've got uh
William from Denver, Colorado. William,
thank you for your patience. You're on
Bible Answers Live with Pastor Doug.
Well, good evening, gentlemen. How are
you
doing? Well, how are you?
Well, I'm doing good. I've got the
easiest answer for you over the night.
Okay.
Okay. A couple of weeks ago, I had the
great privilege of spending about three
hours with four gentlemen arguing
different aspects of the Bible.
Okay? And of course, we didn't agree on
a whole lot of it, but it was it was a
good discussion. The biggest thing that
I had struggle with is one of the
gentlemen said, "There is no way the
Bible can be 100% accurate when it was
written by man."
And man has been given the free will to
do whatever he wants. And because we
know that there are writings similar to
the Bible by the same authors that have
been not included, how can we know that
the Bible as it sits is the Bible in a
in total and it's as AC is and is
accurate without error or inherent.
All right, good question. And by the
way, the the gift I just offered our
previous easy.
Yeah. Well, I don't know that it's easy,
but it's a good question.
Um the um the gift I offered on our
previous caller is just addressing this
exa uh specifically and that's we'll
send you the book called the ultimate
resource. It's about the Bible. But now
let me get your question. Um I think
you're always safer believing when God
says in the Bible, thy word is truth and
every word of God is pure. And you look
in the Bible, it says all scripture was
given by inspiration of God. God has
supernaturally preserved this book. It's
not like the Quran. It's not like the
Bghdavida or any other uh supposed
sacred writing. The Bible has really
stood the test of time. And I've been to
Israel. I've been to the museum where
the Dead Sea Scrolls are. I stood next
to a a Jewish scholar who was uh we were
looking at the Isaiah scroll together.
He could read ancient Hebrew and I asked
him I pointed to a spot on the scroll. I
said, "Can you read that to me?" and
he's reading now a copy of the Bible
that's 2,000 years old, over 2,000 years
old. And um and I know my Bible pretty
well. And he started reading the part of
Isaiah where Hezekiah is surrounded by
the Assyrians and Sekarb was mocking and
the Rab Shaka was threatening God. And
and it's exactly like my Bible today.
And it's 2,000 years. I just got chills
because I thought, "Wow, here we are
2,000 years later and God has done
something supernatural to preserve this
word." Um, if it was just written by
men, then you're right, we would have
messed it up. But these were the words
of God. And God was very particular to
make sure when people were copying the
Bible that uh they just put the most
careful attention into detail to make
sure that they were carefully
reproduced. And so as I told our
previous caller
um and and then the other thing was the
assembly of the books of the Bible that
we have them now. Why does it seem like
some books are left out?
That's a kind of a popular myth. the
books by the time the Apostle John died,
the books that are now included in our
New Testament, of course, before Jesus
lived, they already had the books of the
Old Testament, so there was no question
about that. But by the time that John
died, the books that we now have in our
New Testament were recognized by the
church as inspired. There were several
councils and discussions about should
they add another one or not. To play it
safe, they left certain ones out. But
that doesn't mean that what we have is
not 100% inspired.
Um there were some books that they
thought were dubious
or doubtful or maybe they should not be
included in the sacred cannon, but the
ones that were included they were
extremely careful for. And let me give
you an example how they made those
decisions.
Um Peter refers to the writings of Paul
as scripture.
Jude refers to Peter as scripture.
There's a cross-pollination that happens
throughout the New Testament where they
validate one another and they were very
careful that it all was in harmony and
that there was no contradiction between
the the authors in the New Testament and
they referenced one another. And so the
books that we've got in our Bible today
are as sacred as anything you're ever
going to find. And uh I'm not saying
that there might not be a scribal error
or that translators haven't made
mistakes. That's different from the
actual Bible being inspired
because human I can take a Bible and
mess it up if I want to. Anyone can try
to mess it up,
but the the originals that we have, it's
an inspired message from God. Hey, I'm
going to try and get another caller.
William, can I send you that free book
called The Ultimate Resource?
That would be great. Thanks. All right,
just call that number 8008356747.
Appreciate it.
Our next question is from Chris in
Chico. Chris, you're on Bible Answers
Live with Pastor Doug.
Well, hi Pastor Doug. Good evening.
Evening.
Um my question is um I was talking with
a friend of mine and um their religion
says that the when we repent of the sins
are not blotted out until the great day
of the final award. And um I'm arguing
that in the Bible in Colossians and
several places, as soon as you um repent
of your sins, they're forgiven and gone
forever. Never never to come up again.
Yeah. I think that confuses people. Uh
I'm in the middle. Let me I know that
sounds like I'm running for public
office, but what I mean by that is it is
true. As soon as we come to the Lord and
we repent of our sins, he takes our
sins, he casts them into the depths of
the sea, he forgives us. But the final
dealing with our sins doesn't happen
until the great judgment day. And
ultimately, um a lot of sin is the
devil. Anybody who is not forgiven by
the blood of Christ, they pay for their
own sins, right? Or let's suppose
somebody comes to the Lord and they say,
"Lord, I'm sorry for my sins. Please
forgive me." He says, "You're forgiven."
But then they won't forgive their
neighbor.
Their forgiveness is withdrawn. And
that's Jesus' own words. He says in
Matthew 18 that if after the king
forgives this this servant that was in
debt. He says when you failed to forgive
your fellow servant I'm now going to
make you pay for everything you because
you did not share my forgiveness with
others. And Jesus says in the Lord's
prayer forgive us our debts as we
forgive our debtors. So if believers
refuse to pass on the forgiveness of God
and if we turn and from our sins as you
know Peter says a dog returns to
then you know our our forgiveness can be
uh invalidated by God if we don't
trust him. That's all that I think is
meant by that.
Yeah. I mean, if if you know, I'm a
spiritfilled believer and, you know, I
forgive anybody, you know, that, you
know, sins against me is not a problem
at all because I know God forgave me.
And then I look at Hebrews 10:17, which
says, "I will remember their sins and
their lawless teach no more." And I
think no more, there's not too much gray
area. You know, they're gone as soon as
you confess them.
That's true. Yeah, he does. He forgives
you. In other words, you should you
should walk before God with a clear
conscience that he's forgiven your sins.
Now after you've become a Christian and
you love the Lord, you may still sin
and need to repent again.
A matter of fact, you can count on that.
Uh you know,
daily it's a daily occurrence.
Yeah. Bible says we stumble in many
things and so we frequently have to come
and repent and and get a refreshing so
to speak.
So I think we're on the same page as far
as that's concerned.
Right. Okay.
Hey, thank you very much, Chris.
Appreciate your your uh question. Very
good one.
Next we have Eddie from Fairfax,
Virginia. Eddie, you're on the line with
Bible Answers Live and Pastor Doug.
Eddie, we got two minutes. Can we do it?
Yes.
Okay.
Okay. So, so I'm studying with another
Bible leader regarding the health laws
and he uses Mark 7:19 as the end all
beall verse where Jesus said that at the
end of verse 19, Jesus said in saying
this, Jesus declared all foods clean.
Now, you're reading from the New
International Version, aren't you?
Yeah.
Yeah. You look in other versions, it
doesn't say that. And that's they took
great liberty with that verse the way it
reads in the original. And if you look
in the King James version, it says in
saying it, it said it does that not even
in the King James, it says um thus
purging all meats. And Christ said that
what you put into your mouth does not
defile you. And he's talking about it's
not food that defiles your soul. And he
says, ' Because when you eat something,
if you've eaten something with unwashed
hands is what Jesus is talking about, it
just goes through your system and it's
eliminated. It's very different from
what they did with the NIV version. They
tried to make Jesus say that he made
some declaration that all food is now
clean. Problem is, if you go to Acts
chapter 10, Peter says, "Not so, Lord. I
have never eaten anything common and
unclean." And Paul makes or Peter makes
that statement three and a half years
after Jesus has gone to heaven. So they
never got the idea from Jesus that he
declared all foods clean. Um and so you
don't find that there. Hey, we do have a
lesson on clean and unclean foods. It's
called God's Free Health Plan. We'll
send you a free copy if you'd like.
Eddie, you can hear the background music
and if you simply go to our call
8008356747,
ask for God's free health plan.
listening friends. I hope you've been
blessed by Bible Answers Live this week.
If you have, let us know. Go to
amazingfacts.org.
Contact us and help us stay on the air.
We sure appreciate it. Talk next week.
[Music]
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts, a faith-based ministry located in
Sacramento, California.
[Music]
Deep within the pages of the Bible,
stories of great heroes,
heroes of great deeds,
great love,
and great sacrifice.
But behind them is another hero, hidden
in plain sight amid the shadows.
He was there from the beginning.
And he'll be there until the end.
Discover the golden thread of a Savior
woven throughout the entire Bible
tapestry.
Shadows of Light.
Seeing Jesus in all the Bible, a new
book by Doug Bachelor.
Get your copy today by calling
8005387275
or visit afbookstore.com.
Once again, to purchase your copy of
Shadows of Light, call 8005387275.
In 6 days, God created the heavens and
the earth. For thousands of years, man
has worshiped God on the seventh day of
the week. Now each week, millions of
people worship on the first day. What
happened? Why did God create a day of
rest? Does it really matter what day we
worship? Who is behind this great shift?
Discover the truth behind God's law and
how it was changed. Visit
sabathtruth.com.
If you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word, visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org.
o rg and sign up for our free Bible
study course. And make sure to check out
our online bookstore at
afookbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books, DVDs, and more to help you get
the most out of God's word. To take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast, call us at 8008356747
or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org.
Did you enjoy this program? Make sure to
tell your family and friends. Tune in
next time for more Bible Answers Live.
Honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions.
[Music]